ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد الازمه في
السودان تقترب من الشهر وتصعد العسكري لم
يهدا حتى حرب تصريحات لم تتوقف حميتي
سيواجه بتهمه الخيانه العظمى تصريحنا على
اللسان القيادي البارز في الجيش السوداني
الفريق ياسر العطا على الرغم من المحادثات
الجاريه بين الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم
السريع في جده الفريق في الجيش السوداني
اوضح لصحيفه الشرق الاوسط ان الجيش يسيطر
بالكامل على جميع ولايات السودان لكنه
استثنى بعض الجيوب التي قال انها تحت
سيطره الدعم السريع متهما اعلامها بالكذب
بغرض رفعي معنوية عناصرها واضاف القائد
العسكري ان قوات من اسمائهم بالمتمردين قد
تم تدميرها في معركه القياده العامه التي
وصفها بانها ام المعارك واوضح ان هدف
الحوار بالنسبه للجيش هو من الخرطوم خارج
القوات الدعم السريع
وحصرها في واحد تمهيدا لضم العناصر
الصالحه منها الى الجيش وتسريح الباقي
ومحاكمته كبار قاده الدعم السريع وفق قوله
وتهمل فريق يسر العطاء عناصر فاجنر
بالتدخل في القتال لصالح قوات الدعم
السريع بهدف الحفاظ على عمليات استخراج
الذهب كما قال من جانب اخر كشفت مصادر
دبلوماسيه مطلعه للعربيه ان التوقيع على
اتفاق اولي بشان الهدنه بين طرفي الصراع
سيتحقق في جده وان تحديدا موعد التوقيع
مرتبط بالاتفاق على بنود يجري النقاش
حولها حاليا كما افادت مصادر العربيه بان
بعض مطالب الجيش ودعم السريع قد اجلتها
الوساطه للمرحله الثانيه من التفاوض
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من لندن طيب
الزينه صحفيه السودانيه اهلا بك وبعد قليل
مفروض ينضم لنا كذلك ضيفنا اللواء الركن
المتقاعد اسامه محمد عبد السلام سنبقى في
انتظاره على ان ينضم لنا لمشاركتنا هذا
النقاش ولكن اسمح لي ان ابدا معك سيد
الطيب سيد الطيب البعض علق على موضوع
التصريحات مقابل المواقف الحقيقيه على
الارض هي تتعارض تتباين تتضارب حتى
التصريحات نراها في جزء منها ايجابيه بان
هناك جلوس على الطاوله ومحاوله لايجاد
حلول وقبول للهدى ولكن المواقف تتحدث عن
استمرار هذه الاشتباكات حتى وان انحسرت في
مناطق معينه ما التفسير
بدايه التحيه ولمشاهدين قناه
العربيه
وفيما يتعلق
بالتصريحات
والتباين ما بين المواقف على الارض وما
بين التصريحات يعني حسب تقديري انه
البرهان ومعه
ياسر العطا والقباشي وكل بقايا النظام
الموجودين في قمه المؤسسه العسكريه هم لا
يؤمنون لا يمثلون هذه المؤسسه العسكريه لا
في عقيدتها ولا في دورها ولا في موقفها
تجاه مساله التحول الديمقراطي فيما يتعلق
بتصريحات ياسر ولكن صيد الطيب حتى وان
كانت هذه الاسماء بحسب رؤيه حضرتك لا يمكن
ان تمثل العقيده العسكريه السودانيه يمكن
ان ياتي
يعني ممكن ان تاتي بعض الترتيبات من داخل
مؤسسه الجيش ولكن هل تعتقد بانه حل هكذا
مشكله كما وصفتها يمكن ان ياتي
بالاشتباكات
طبعا لا يعني كل كل الناس في السودان وكل
العالم من حولنا
مجموعين على ان المخرج او المدخل
لمعالجه هذه الازمه هو الحوار وهو السلام
ومن هذا الباب
انا لا اتوقع انه البرهان والعطى
والكباشي ومن خلفهم طبعا من خلف الكواليس
كل النظام السابق هم لا يرقبون في سلام
ولا يرغبون في امن ولا يرغبون في استقرار
في البلد فلذلكم يصرون على هذه الحرب وهذه
الفوضى لانهم ولكن هل يرغب بها الدعم
السريع من جهه اخرى كذلك قد يقول لك بعضهم
بان الدعم السريع هو كذلك طرف في هذه
الاشتباكات والواقع يقول بان الدعم السريع
فقد الكثير من مراكز سيطرته بعد هذه المده
من الاشتباكات يعني ما الذي استفاد منه في
هذه المرحله حتى تسقط كل هذه الارواح
طبعا
اليسرى
والبرهان
هما من حقهم من يصرحوا ويدعوا انهم حقه
انتصارات لكن الواقعه الارض والوقايه على
الارض تقول بان القوات الدعم السريعيه
المسيطره على العاصمه على المراجع
الاستراتيجيه عن الطرق الرئيسيه
يعني ما في وجود للفلول في
العاصمه في الكلام الذي يقال هو مجرد يعني
تمنيات اكثر منها هي قدرات الواقع ولكن
ليس كلام فقط وهنا اعذرني ان انقل وجهه
نظر الجيش لانه ضيفنا غير جاهز معنا هو
المفروض يكون حاضر بوجهه نظر كذلك نفهم
منها هذا التباين في الاراء ولكن اسمح لي
ان انقل لك بعض التصريحات هم لا ينشرون
فقط تصريحاتهم ينشرون كذلك صور موثقه
فيديوهات
ويؤكدون من خلالها بانهم
على معظم مناطق العاصمه الخرطوم
اذا كان هم سيطروا على المواقع الرئيسيه
معناها الحرب انتهت يعني لماذا تكون هناك
حرب يعني لماذا لا يعني في التلفزيون بيان
رسمي يؤكدون انهم سيطروا على الواقع يعني
لا وجود له في الاذاعه لا وجود لهم في
الشارع مع الناس
في المطار لا وجود لهم في القياده العامه
لا وجود لهم في المراكز الرئيسيه سواء كان
في معامل تكرير النفط باستخراج النفط كلها
الى هذه المواقع الاستراتيجيه هم ما عندهم
فيها وجودها هذه المناطق طيب طالما لازلنا
نتحدث سيد الطيب في اطار هذه الاشتباكات
وهذا التصعيد العسكري ما فائده المحادثات
ما فائده المفاوضات
المفاوضات الهدف منها حتى يقتنعوا بانه
الحرب هي خيار فاشل لانهم هم قبل ما يعني
تبدا المعارك دي الفلول فلول النظام
السابق كان بيقولوا انهم سيحسموا الامور
في خلال ساعات
وخدعوا البرهان ومعه اللجنه الامنيه بانكم
اذا يعني قمتوا بعمليه قادره تستطيعون ان
تسيطروا على قوات الدعم السريع وهي في
قفله من امرها وبامكانكم ان تنجزوا المهمه
في ساعات وجيزه لكن كانت الحسابات خاطئه
لانه معتقدوا ان الدعم السريع يعني من
السهل يعني يعني السيطره عليه لكن تفاجاوا
بقوات الدعم السريع وبصبرها وبسباتها
وكفاح وحتى الان يعني دخلنا في الاسبوع
الرابع
ودعم السريع هي
بقايا النظام السابق هؤلاء هم يمتطوا
الجيش فهو للجيش كما امتطوا يوم من الايام
الدين الدين الاسلامي القيم وفي كل ما فيه
من فضائل ومن معاني ساميه هذا الدين قاموا
بامتلاف
الحروب وصلوا الجنوب واجدوا الحرب ونشروا
العنصريه ودمروا الاقتصاد وجعلوا من
السودان يقود في الوحل الان حينما قامت
الثوره السوداني كله اتحد في انه يبني
دوله عصريه دوله ديمقراطيه دوله مدنيه
ايضا اصروا على ان يعيدوا في السودان
ولذلك
هو في الواقع نعم وضحت فتره حضرتك سيد
الطيب هو في الواقع وددنا ان نكون امام
وجهتي نظر ولكن لم نتمكن اليوم لاسباب
تقنيه الاكيد باننا سنبقى في متابعه هذه
التطورات شكرك على كل ما تفضلت بحولت ان
انقل على قدر الامكان وجهه نظر الجيش
السوداني لفهم كذلك ان كان هناك نقاط
التقاء
السابع معكم كلمه اخيره باقتضاب انت كرمت
انا اقول انه المخرج من هذه الازمه وبعوده
يعني البرهان لا
عندي شاب على الحكومه المدنيه اذا هو
متمرد على الشعب السوداني الدعم السريع
تحالف معه يعني نحن تجاوزنا هذا التاريخ
سيقول لك بعضكم بعضهم هكذا شكرا جزيلا لك
سيد الطيب الزين الصحفي السوداني كنت معنا
من الخرطوم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات